hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to will you press the
button now it's been a while so I want
to make sure that when I do these
questions they are as devastating to as
many people as possible if I can wipe
out entire countries for even a modicum
of power you know I'm gonna press that
button it seems a lot less threatening
when I'm very shorn in baby face like
this but that's just to get under your
skin and so you don't suspect anything
and then I'll stab you in the back
but I'll be real cute about it okay so
you can speak every language fluently
but you cannot read or write in any of
them now this is actually a dilemma
if you if you speak every language
fluently and I'm assuming this is every
language universally so I'm assuming
it's anywhere if there are aliens and
they do have language which I'm assuming
there are and they do then you would be
able to speak those weird languages but
not that that would mean anything to
anyone you could just be like it's an
alien language guys trust me it's an AI
only I know it and the aliens but I know
that well they'd be a little worried but
then they would have to take your word
for it because you can speak absolutely
every language on earth and then they
would have to assume that you're correct
but not being able to read or write it
you would never be able to record it you
wouldn't even be able to dictate to
someone I think this weird language has
an a shape to it for that letter you
wouldn't be able to do any of that so
it's a bit of a trade off but I never be
able to read again I don't read
instructions anyway so fraggin let's
present if I'm gonna justify anything
about this is that my [ __ ] excuses
are applicable you can fly anywhere but
you have to go to the restroom every 10
minutes I mean it's not telling me that
I have to go to the restroom and do
something I could just build a toilet in
every room of my house and I've got to
be and when you're flying I mean what's
the prob drop trou start [ __ ] all
over the place no one's gonna stop you
you're frickin flying piss on everybody
you're flying over their heads
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ] you I'm
the [ __ ] on your dreams
I fly over your house yeah I'm gonna do
that do that that's amazing I surely to
that you live a perfect life a good job
plenty of friends and a soul mate who
loves you dearly but you have to live
life as the opposite sex yes [ __ ] it
great sounds cool why wouldn't I do that
you can experience the feeling of an
orgasm whenever you want but you can't
have sex does that mean like I'm
physically incapable like I can't figure
out how to put peg a in the slot V okay
I just can't do it I can't oh oh God oh
no I could be in a relationship and then
just not have sex you do that anyway
called marriage yeah
did I nail the joke no I'm good I'm good
on my own any Pokemon you want will
become real but you have to treat it
with the same amount of respect you'd
give any animal where it will vanish how
I treat any animal not a specific animal
a nyan but if Pokemon were real I
wouldn't abuse it but oh oh my god I get
it okay so it's saying like I don't know
why my mind went eh I'm not gonna eat
this Pokemon like I don't know what it's
getting at I'm not I'm not gonna eat it
like of course it doesn't want you to
eat it
it doesn't want you to battle with it
because dog fighting is illegal and
horrible so I guess if it wants you to
actually assume that these Pokemon are
gonna be fighting for you that's no cool
but if they're gonna be a friend that's
totally fine they could you can make it
fly I can get an Alakazam and it'd be
able to it has an IQ of like ninety
bajillion and be able to do anything I'd
be cool yeah hell yeah hell yeah I mean
I give animals respect all the time she
could disrespect me back but I mean it's
about the same you can go back in time
bring anything you want with you but
Hitler when
is the war ooh now the question is what
do you bring back and why is it worth it
and I'm assuming by the war they mean
World War two and I'm assuming that
generally means he conquers everything
he wanted to conquer which was the whole
world so the whole world is now Nazi
okay some people would logically
conclude you would bring back like
either technology or something cool into
the past and then hopefully that would
have a profound effect on the future and
maybe World War two wouldn't happen but
I'm assuming by the context here
Hitler winning World War two is a
constant in time it's intangible he
cannot not win so if you bring
technology back far enough you actually
affect the technology curve of society
and not only does he win he wins with
even more technologically advanced
weapons and he blows up everything and
everything is horrible even more so with
robots and [ __ ] yeah I know I have an
infatuation with like the past but the
past was bad people died a lot they
didn't have like penicillin and
antibiotics and [ __ ] they didn't have
food then a lot more war than there is
now I mean a lot of people died in World
War two but that's a constant here we
can't do anything about that so no no no
no no you gain all the knowledge of the
Internet but you get turrets where you
random provably shout out sex sounds
you get turrets shooty shooty bang bang
turrets I'm gonna take this literally
it's not Tourette's
it's turrets I have turrets on my house
pouring in red direction and they're
like whatever they see motion someone's
walking down the street they're like red
Oh little mom pushing your baby on a
stroller whoosh oh yeah get it
that's no no that's not what anyone says
like when they're having sex but I I
don't know what anyone says I'm just a
young boy of 13 I I've never even
imagine what that is yeah hell yeah I'm
gonna do that well I want the sex
turrets I have won all the sex turrets
and see you become a millionaire and
live a long healthy life but every day
at exactly 6 p.m. you must sit deadly
still on a chair for an hour and do
nothing without fail could I sleep I
mean doing nothing I mean there's
literally nothing more do nothing than
sleeping because you're not doing
anything you're literally doing nothing
so every day at 6 p.m. I have a power
nap I me that's it pretty cool and then
you're fine and then you go about your
day a happy long live millionaire Tybee
doesn't know downside you will be rich
and famous but you can only speak in
Shakespeare quotation so you'll be able
to speak eloquently with fine litter
cheerio Rico Oates but everyone is gonna
think you're a giant douche and hate you
ah better to be a better ass [ __ ] Oh
I'll press it alright you can go back in
time and make different choices on any
day of your life you wish but you then
return to the present with no memories
of how that choice affected your life
and you can never regain those memories
again so what you're saying is if I go
back and have a different conversation
with Sally [ __ ] ins worth I wouldn't
know the outcome of that particular
action but it would have occurred so I'd
go back talking to Sally [ __ ] ins Worth
put a lot of money in Apple stock right
before and then I go to the future with
a slightly different life ah I don't
know seems fine I mean it doesn't say I
don't have to do it and let's see world
peace but a quarter of the world
population dies
well world peace forever and ever or
world peace for a little bit or world
peace for something that's gonna kill
1.5 something more than that probably
like two billion people now that's a lot
of people but if I recall about
something that I said in the beginning
of this episode here it is I'm gonna
sweep devastation all across the country
and the world to bring about world peace
I will press this button don't worry
guys I'm gonna bear this burden I'll do
I got it I got this guy's
I got this story I got this okay BAM I
did it okay we did all right who's alive
ah [ __ ] oh [ __ ] this is a good one okay
I'm gonna end the episode here and give
you this question anyone you hate
instantly dies but that includes
individuals you otherwise liked but
happen to be very angry with at the
moment and know you can't suddenly
forgive them and be okay with them if
you were angry with them that day or
even that week they will die anyone so
will you press that button I'll leave
that up to you so thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video bye
[Music]